hey guys Pete here I'm going to go back
in episode here and do a Q&A for the
questions that you guys left in the
comments of all my 20 season 3 part 7
videos this is your spoiler warning if
you haven't watched part 7 yet then
you're going to want to stop watching
now but I do have plenty of videos for
the past episode so why don't you go
watch one of those in the meantime
alright so the first question is what
makes you think that evil coupe was with
Diane the last time so this is in
relation to I said in my other video
that I thought something bad must have
went down and between Diane and evil
Cooper and really that's the basis for
my thinking I don't see what would have
happened if she's talking about seeing
the original Agent Dale Cooper
that would give her this reaction when
she asked the question beyond that I
don't have any extra information
the next question is related to the same
subject what talk do you think that
Gordon and Diane are going to have later
well pretty simply I think she's going
to explain what happened the last time
that she saw Cooper he asked her if
there's something that she needs to know
that he needs to know about that last
meeting or that last night so I'm
guessing that she's so flustered at this
moment that she just wants to sit down
and talk to him at a different time
rather than get into the whole thing
next question if Leland wanted to
destroy the diary pages why didn't he
flush them down the toilet instead of
hiding them in the stall door but I
think this is probably something that
Bob did for what it's worth there but
that isn't exactly clear how that works
anyways but I mean I think that if
anything Leland might not wanted to
destroy the pages we don't know what's
on all of them we know there's some
incriminating stuff and that's why he
tore them out but perhaps it was just
that he wanted to still have a
connection with his daughter or maybe
there's something else there that's
important that we just don't know about
yet but you're right I mean he could
have destroyed them and they wouldn't
exist anymore but then we wouldn't had
this cool reveal if that was the case
either right next question asks why is
the evolution of the arm helping Cooper
well this is confusing to me as well but
you know we could think of it in a way
is
like he's not necessarily helping dougie
coop here what he's doing is he is
working against evil coot if we think
about what we know about the Red Room
and the lodge and everything else
What evil Cooper's doing is he's going
against what they want they wanted him
to come back so we know in the past you
know like when Bob sorta went rogue that
was about as a problem so I'm assuming
that at the very least everything that
evil Coop's doing is a problem for them
on some level and they want Bob to come
back so he can hand over the Garmin Bo
Xia so like I don't know we'll have to
see I mean it could be that the
evolution of the arm has actually
changed I've talked about this in other
videos you know I assume that the arm is
supposed to be evil but when we see his
doppelganger it's pretty unequivocally
evil though it's not really clear who's
good or who's bad there hopefully
episode 8 you know gave us some insights
into things so hopefully we'll get more
insight before the season's over next
question was how awesome does it feel to
be spectating a 25 year old mystery
getting some closure and it is awesome I
think it's great I know a lot of people
wanted to be like the series was when it
first came out 25 years ago but I am
completely ok with them taking us in any
direction because we are as the cook you
know the commenter said there that we
are getting answers and that's great as
far as I'm concerned next question was
can the jet window blinking be
translated into notes for some kind of
flute and I also got a ton of thing
saying that it was just sunlight and it
was bad editing and so on and so forth
there was a really detailed post about
this and I will put the link in the
description here that you can go look at
after I read that I was pretty
comfortable in saying that that had been
done that that had been added in
in post-production basically people who
know a lot more about this kind of thing
say that it was so I don't have any
reason to dispute that I have never
played a flute or have any idea about
that so maybe someone here might know
more about that to me but you know I I
don't know if that has to do with the
flute or not but several people have
brought that idea up next question was
did anyone notice when the oily guy was
walking down the hallway that we heard
the same sound that we heard from the
giant's record player this is something
that I have talked about in a few videos
so I won't rehash the whole thing but in
my opinion there are two different
sounds there's the one that he plays for
Cooper on the record player and then
there's the one that we hear in relation
to most of these scenes where something
dark seems to be happening you can go
back and watch them both the first time
I hear the sound that we hear most often
now was in the hallway in the Red Room
in part 2 when Cooper's trying to leave
if they play it over top of an image of
what I think was the Venus de Milo I
know there's different meatiness statues
there but one of them they play it there
that turns out to be the arms
doppelganger so I thought that this
sound was connected to that but honestly
we don't know for sure but when you
listen to the Giants it sounds like it's
a it's a pattern like it's not that same
sort of electronic hum and electric
scratching or whatever it actually is
next question was do you think Bob is in
control of Cooper's doppelganger
this was the question that I've had
since the very beginning I don't know
that we found out a lot more about it it
seems to me that the possession of evil
coop is different than what we saw with
the possession of Leland like Leland
seem to be able to function and then Bob
would take over here that seems like
their relationships different we've seen
where evil coop had good you're still
here in the mirror
I guess in general their motivations
would be similar but I really don't know
I mean I could speculate and ramble on
about it I guess I think the most
important thing here is that to me it's
always struck me as being different than
what we saw in the original first two
seasons and in fire walk with me and
this could be for a number of reasons
this could be because Leland was
possessed as a young child he welcomed
Bob in or it could be about the fact
that Cooper's just a stronger being so
he can't really control him in the same
way I don't know next question is does
it Lucy have some weird phobia about
technology this is in relation to the
super awesome computer setup that Frank
Truman has and saying that maybe that
was that way because it's not to freak
Lucy out or whatever and a couple of you
have brought that up
I don't know that Lucy has a phobia with
technology per se but it does seem like
she has a very fixed idea that when
she's talking to somebody on the phone
that means they're far away that you
know there was a scene this season and
the people have brought up the fact that
there was a cutscene from the missing
pieces so I don't know what's up with it
but maybe we'll find out a little bit
more in the future of the season next
question was evil creep had some
incriminating stuff on the warden so
they just let him go yeah I thought it
was a little bit weird that they did
that but when I think back about it
let's not forget that he also did that
crazy thing with the phone whenever they
were watching him make his one call and
I think it's been implied pretty well
that whatever he knows about the warden
is something the warden cannot live with
getting out so yeah it's a little bit
strange that he would just let him go
but at the same time I think he has
pretty good reason to fear What evil
coupe could do next question did you get
the sense that the Pentagon woman did
not actually see the oily guy when she
turned around I said it in the recap and
review I really don't know she may have
been aware of his presence or got a
strange feeling but nothing about the
scene indicates that she actually saw
him that said in episode 8 which I'm not
going to spoil here because maybe you
didn't watch it yet but
my understanding of that may have
changed a little bit there next question
was isn't Tammi Tamera Preston who is
the same person who compiled the dossier
for the secret history well see what she
didn't compile it they got the dossier S
is what she did was as assigned by
Gordon Cole she went through to verify
the statements that were within so most
of the different documents and things
that were collected there she left notes
in the margins and things like that to
say that she went back and found out
that whatever the archivist was saying
was true next question did anyone notice
that Laura Palmer / Sheryl Lee was
credited in the end of the episode yeah
she has been credited in every single
episode Upton to this point and my best
guess is because they show her photo in
the opening credits scene I remember
when we first got the actors and I am DB
that it said she was in all 18 episodes
so that could be related to that as well
next question oMG doesn't anyone
remember that the fourth diary page was
the one in the train car from the night
of Laura's murder my memory of this was
that they did find pages or a page in
the train car that they realized were
from a different diary than the one they
had and fire walk with me in that scene
you can see that Leland has pages in his
hand and I haven't been able to go back
and watch every scene that relates to
these diary pages to know for sure but
the reason that I brought that up in the
10 things video was because I thought
that Hawk was saying in a kind of
specific way that there was still one
that was missing and since he was
familiar with the original investigation
he would know that there were you know
there were other pages in evidence or a
page in evidence or whatever so that was
my thinking at the time it could be
completely wrong but we'll just have to
wait and see next question was am I the
only person that noticed that the guy
playing jean-michele is the same actor
that played John this is something that
I didn't point out again in the most
recent episode I had mentioned it in my
which character is a returning video and
the very first recap and review I did 4
parts 1 & 2 and yes the same actor who
played jock who's dead is playing this
new character Jean Michelle Renault now
you might be I've been thinking about
his brother he had two brothers in the
original series he had Bernard who was
the younger brother and then there was
John Renault who was sort of like the
ringleader the actor the play John is
dead and this is just a brand new
Renault we don't really know where he
came from but they got the same actor
who plays Jacques to play this guy so
that's the way it is I don't know if
we're going to get a backstory on him or
not next question that coupe went into
Audrey's room could this be how Richard
Horne came to be well there's certainly
a lot of theory about that going around
it's possible because we know that evil
coupe is about character I guess you
know but I mean there's some problems
with that idea
ICU is not a place where you can just
walk in and do what you will in the room
without anybody knowing it's going on
and you know there's the alternate idea
of what I said you know that there could
be other reasons for him going there the
I'll cave ring seems to be the most
obvious thing but also there's the idea
of Annie being there and all we really
know from Doc Hayward is that he saw
Cooper coming out by the ICU and he
assumed that he went to see and check on
Audrey we're going to have to get some
more info on that but we do know that
the Al Cave ring came back into his
possession at some point and that the
last time we knew about it it was in the
possession of the nurse who took it from
Annie and the last question is what
happened to Annie
I forgot did she die well I made a whole
video about any last weekend that you
can check out so I won't add a bunch
about that here the short answer is that
we don't really know last we heard she
was okay and we assumed that she was
recovering but beyond that we just
really don't know yet alright guys
thanks for all the questions it's fun to
do these and I will be doing one for
part eight really soon please like the
video if you enjoyed it and subscribe to
my channel to stay up to date with all
my twin peaks' videos thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon